some people think God created the
universe some people think nothing
created the universe which is the
funniest guess and then nothing people
make fun of the God people they say God
doesn't exist I'm like okay maybe but
you know what definitely doesn't exist
nothing that's the defining
characteristic of nothing is that it
doesn't exist so what are we talking
about either you think it's God
something you can't see touch taste
photograph and science can't prove or
you think it's nothing something you
can't see touch Tastee photograph and
science can't prove I think we can all
agree if nothing if you're nothing
sometimes spontaneously erupts into
everything that's a pretty goddamn
magical [__] nothing you guys ask the
nothing people what happens when you die
they'll tell you nothing you go into
nothing I'm like you mean you merge back
with your
creator that's Heaven [__]